difficile encore la répression et la
prévention
attendez vous à l'école un rapport du
sénat
china nouveau cours sur les libertés
devant les leaders de pékin des agences
proposent aujourd'hui la location de
bateaux madame monsieur bonsoir tout
comme les conseillères les allemands
très chaud cet après midi à montpellier
face au mexique mené 1-0 jusqu'à un
quart d'heure de la fin ils l'ont
finalement emporté 2 1
confirmant le dicton qui affirme le
football est un jeu qui se joue à onze
et dont les allemands sont vainqueurs et
solutions allemagne mexique certains
pensaient peut-être que ça ne changerait
pas la phase de la coupe du monde avec
leur football efficace et leurs
supporters banane on voyait les
allemands gagnent et de la tête et du
chapeau eh bien c'était une erreur car
comme les français hier nos voisins
d'outre-rhin ont frôlé la
correctionnelle de la coupe du monde
déjà en première période ils mexicains
font les petites misères coop que le
gardien allemand
plus tard réplique des blancs dont on ne
peut pas dire qu'ils jouent mal
simplement pire envoie le ballon sur la
barre alors qu'il était plus simple
employé dans les buts mais minuteur ça
ne marche pas à tous les coups une
occasion de perdue on retrouve les
mexicains juste avant la mi temps
valencia seul devant coop qui détourne
00 c'est la pause deuxième période a
commencé pour le mexique qui ouvre le
score grâce à luis hernandez qu'on
l'appelle paraît-il le matador bien
qu'il joue son costume à paillette
mexique y mène 1-0 pour une surprise
ça c'est une bonne surprise chose rare
pendant quelques minutes les allemands
sont ko et sans ce petit brin de
réussite qui fait souvent leur bonheur
il se serait retrouvé mené 2 à 0 les
allemands parfois le football mais le
père de la belle morale et ça c'est une
qualité
il reste un quart d'heure à jouer petite
erreur urbaine qui une fois n'égalise
et revoilà l'allemagne dans la course
encore quatre minutes de jeu dans la
prolongation tout est possible mais
soudain pour le mexique ou les olives
les rov marque de la tête dit rov c'est
monsieur plus le gars qui sauve son
équipe des situations difficiles
les mexicains auraient pu gagner cette
rencontre
oui mais voilà les allemands
comme l'inspecteur derrick il donne
toujours à la fin les bleus eux qui hier
nous en ont fait voir des vertes et des
pas mûres avec leur qualification in
extremis contre le paraguay sont
aujourd'hui de retour à clairefontaine
leur camp d'entraînement
c'est l'objectif désormais les quarts de
finale vendredi contre l'italie au stade
de france ne sera pas faire même si à
cette occasion l'équipe enregistrera le
retour de son stratège zinédine zidane
vient de la voix
les organismes étaient au repos ce matin
les esprits aussi le rituel décrassage
de lendemain de match a pour but
d'éliminer les fatigues physiques et
psychiques
alors on s'étire on discute aussi par
atelier les bleus se répartissent selon
leur état de fraîcheur
beaucoup disent avoir terminé hier
épuisé les prolongations j'avais des
crabes
j'étais pratiquement un spectateur je
n'arrivais plus à courir j'ai essayé
d'occuper deux ans pour être le plus
utile pour l'équipe même enjeu terme
cuissardes et c'est justement le
lendemain lorsque les jambes sont raides
que l'on se souvient de ces instants
vécus comme une délivrance
c'était comme un mur que l'on veut
abattre et qui sait dans la coupe du
monde est unique et les joueurs sont ces
acteurs acteurs spectateurs puisque
aucune image de leur échappe
ils sont comme avide d'émotions quelque
part c'est beau aussi je pense que là on
voit toute la beauté du sport
le but a tout changé en voix on passe
d'une joie immense de l'om détresse
immense fossé et vendredi il faudra
remettre l'art et face à l'item
seulement cette fois la france pourra
compter sur le retour de ce joueur qui
signe surnom d'un z qui veut dire s'ils
gagnent et à qui l'on demandera des
taureaux car l'italie les bleus savent
peut s'avérer être bien plus coriace
encore te le paraguay
il a marqué un but je pense que ça va le
paraguay
enfin nous décidons de faire en sorte
qu'ils essayent de jouer au maximum le
ballon une de pratiquer un football
ouvert
heureusement les français connaissent
bien le foot italien ils sont neuf à
voir jouer ou à jouer encore dans une
équipe transalpine
alors ce sera à eux de montrer aux
autres le chemin de la victoire
quant aux italiens dans leur retraite
près de senlis il se prépare également à
rencontrer les français qu'ils
connaissent très bien dans la mesure où
on viens de vous le dire nos principales
vedettes jouent dans le championnat
italien mathieu chez les dames hemani et
nul à l'aide de sa légion prêts à
marcher sur lutèce cachés derrière leur
thé quelques espions gaulois analyse le
plan de bataille de l'ennemi romain
après l'entraînement vous avez aimé
jacquet quoi de l'expulsion
gérez votre numéro et pourquoi vous
supportez les médaillés par la france le
soutien de lumière mathilde de jeu où
ils sont plus beaux noms les vendredis
entre l'italie et la france
l'esthétisme n'aura pas sa place le
rubicon qui sera difficile à franchir
le score ferrer c'est la vie la presse
italienne
ne sera pas très beau 0-0 tab a pas
beaucoup de buts j'espère pour l'italie
en plus franchement c'est normal je
pense le cardinal nyatto travail pour la
rai il n'a pas manqué une coupe du monde
depuis 1974
pour lui la france part favorite la
france mais yannick françois y animer
bas à 0,2 en mai il ya seulement un but
de différence
j'espère métal prévision n'est pas comme
ça une certitude del piero qui n'a
toujours pas marqué pour la scuderia
pour allart a souvent une vie dans la
déjà terminé avec le mondial lens qui a
accueilli trois matches dont un contre
l'allemagne qui a provoqué un drame
l'agression souvenez vous d'un gendarme
qui se trouvent toujours d'ailleurs dans
un coma profond
c'est ce qu'a indiqué aujourd'hui
l'hôpital de lille louise et en
traitement hier à l'occasion de france
paraguay ce fut la fête bat l'enfant à
lens quel bilan des industriels
commerçants et la ville de la rance tire
le ce mondial pour leur vie et pour la
région
reportage marianne masse patrick boube
quelques 8 en or
le silence y at il une vie après la
coupe à bollaert en tout cas on avait
mis le paquet pour avoir un stade à la
hauteur la plus petite des villes de ce
mondial avait déboursé 100 90 100 francs
sans oublier investir dans les hommes on
a embauché 40 40 volontaires qui étaient
du racing dont les a pris dans nos
équipes interventions étaient des
salariés mais chaque fois qu'on a pu
trouver une solution justement
aujourd'hui la région eh bien on essaie
d'y contribuer derrière lance la petite
ville de 3000 habitants accueillants la
coupe du monde traite un investissement
à plus long terme qui se joue est celui
de l'image de toute une région
vincent champion de france la coupe du
monde est derrière lens il ya une toute
la région qui s'est mobilisé pour dire
saisissez l'occasion de cette coupe du
monde pour montrer comment nous sommes
vraiment à l'âme comme un marché à la
presse entière et comme ça ils
reviendront ceux qui sont venus en temps
tout cas et des l'hôtellerie et marquer
des coins plus disco cran de
fréquentation en moyenne sur tout le
nord-pas-de-calais tel carton rouge
certains ont profité de l'occasion pour
faire flamber les prix il faut que ce
soit payant il faut que ce plan il faut
que ce soit bon marché faut pas vivre
comme certains agents savent le faire en
france et que nos belles manches chacun
peut trouver une chambre de quoi se
restaurer et se désaltérer
même si l'alcool a été interdite une
journée
les débits de boisson se frotte les
mains je vois que le bilan a encore
d'énormes qualités
y at il une vie après le mondial et
demain la pelouse de bollaert libre à
nouveau son des crampons ceux du racing
club de lens
abraham en belgique aujourd'hui
l'explosion d'un camion dans la ville de
stavelot dans l'est du pays les freins
d'un poids lourd ont lâché il comptait
de plusieurs tonnes de produits toxiques
le véhicule a percuté plusieurs maisons
qui se sont enflammées
le bilan ce soir deux morts et une
dizaine de blessés
le centre historique est en grande
partie détruit par les explosions
d'amour par les incendies ensuite le
camion de 13 tonnes transportait des
produits toxiques
ces freins ont sans doute lâcher les
vieux bâtiments du centre-ville n'ont
pas résisté
deux personnes sont mortes sous les
gravats une dizaine d'autres a été
blessé les explosions j'ai compris tout
de suite que c'était les explosions
jaccaud venu j'ai vu une vision
apocalyptique tout le quartier était le
noir en feu
j'ai alors vu en face de moi là où
carrefour est un corps des femmes et sur
la rue on ne sait pas qu'il sait qui est
qui était morte manifestement alors on
s'est dépêché dans les vagues dans les
immeubles pour sauver les gens il ya une
dame qui serait resté dans sa maison n'a
pas pu entrer la halle était trop tard
notre maison est détruite de murmures
pas la première fois il cite un endroit
dangereux
arnaud la quatrième fois la population
de la petite ville croyait son centre
historique à l'abri des poêles ou un
panneau interdit l'accès aux plus de 7
tonnes et le camion fois dévale une
pente à 13% ont utilisé les deux
bretelles et rsa mais n'agit plus haut
tu soir le chauffeur du camion blessés
hospitalisés a été inculpé le dernier
bilan du tremblement de terre de samedi
dernier au sud de la turquie et de 109
morts et plus de 1500 blessés 48 heures
après le drame un enfant de 11 employés
a été miraculeusement le sous les
décombres d'une maison n'est que
légèrement blessé à l'épaule et quelques
heures plus tard c'est une femme d'une
cinquantaine d'années qui a pu être
circuit d'un amas de ciment sans
blessure grave
elle non plus apparemment
face à la violence dans certaines
banlieues difficiles des villes
françaises les pouvoirs publics ont déjà
essayé toute une série de mesures la
répression la prévention la dernière
expérience en bateau les sous bois près
de paris se situe entre les deux il
s'agit pour la police de se montrer
d'être présente sur place du simple
policier en tenue au commissaire
reportage ligne caroff au roi qu'est ce
qu'il ya et c'est un peu la caisse qui a
dû regarder la voiture lui comme ça d'un
oeil un armé gens là vous présentez
l'autorité lui donner un visage
régulièrement le commissaire donné sous
loi seront seuls dans les quartiers les
plus difficiles tous les commerçants qui
sont des noirs une certaine époque lie
pour se plaindre du climat d'insécurité
la mairie annexe ici qui est incendié
plusieurs fois des voitures qui ont été
incendiés dans la cité ce soir c'est
calme mais aussi c'est vrai que certains
canadiens des violences du de plus en
plus souvent à des rivalités entre
bandes
il y a deux mois les jeunes de cette
spirou perdu l'un des leurs lynché dans
un quartier voisin par une vingtaine
d'adolescents
pour les auteurs du rapport sur les
violences urbaines c'est un signal
d'alarmé pas des blancs
la police
avec des banques dans lesquelles on y
rentre parce qu'on a compris que le caïd
du coin
eh bien il n'était plus capable de vous
protéger davantage capable de protéger
que les institutions le constat que
cette équipe de sociologues a pu faire
par exemple ici un policier sur cinq a
été blessé depuis le début de l'année
souvent leur arrestation en flagrant
délit le commissaire doit désormais
envoyer deux ou trois équipes de police
à chaque fois le seul moyen de ne pas se
faire surprendre
l'idée de territoire est très ancrées
parmi les jeunes c'est un moyen pour eux
de se reconnaître
ils n'ont pas beaucoup d'autres repères
et un défaut nous percevoir comme des
troupes d'occupation
il nous perçoivent parfois comme les
huit bandes rivales en quelque sorte qui
vivait sa fille dans leur territoire la
réponse une présence de plus en plus
visible dès que l'occasion se présente
toujours là une société hlm fémur et les
cave d'une cité est devenue le refuge
des squatters une dizaine de policiers
sur place elle va assurer la protection
des ouvriers
le but montrer aux délinquants qu'aucune
partielle du territoire n'est a priori
inaccessible aux forces de l'ordre
un message aussi pour les habitants du
quartier les uniformes sont aujourd'hui
ouvertement partie du décor letestu
réclame 300 millions de francs aux
témoins de jéhovah qui correspond à une
taxe de 60% sur les sommes versées par
les fidèles ces quatre dernières années
c'est une application de la réforme
fiscale de 1992 sur les dos au mouvement
religieux ou une association les témoins
de jéhovah ont dit que deux cent mille
adeptes selon un rapport du sénat il y
aurait en france environ vingt mille
enfants qui ne seraient pas scolarisés
dans des établissements publics ou
encore en contrat avec l'état parmi ceux
ci un peu plus de 5000 pourrait être en
danger
instruits au sein de familles
appartenant à des sectes ou dans des
établissements soupçonnés d'entretenir
des liens avec les scènes c'est en
pensant à eux que est la ministre de
l'enseignement c'est vrai nom royal veut
renforcer les mesures permettant
l'obligation scolaire nathalie moisan
l'école à la maison à la communauté
plutôt ses élèves [ __ ] même les
enfants de dieu merveilleux mad men il
est choisi de faire plus avec trois
enfants une possibilité légale équipe
jusque-là gravement l'objet de contrôles
par ce n'est pas tant parce que ça va
plus la france en personnel et qui
serait moins exposée la violence à la
grappe à l'intérieur de la communauté le
bien et l'amour à l'extérieur le mal et
la douleur un conditionnement manichéen
pour les enfants bien loin des
programmes scolaires et qui peut
s'avérer dangereux rentrée de la société
il est évident qu'un enfant qui ai été
élevé l'enfant qui a vécu
finalement les données essentielles de
de sa vie puis simplement en retrait la
société ne peut pas ensuite reprendre
une place ne comprend pas ce qui se
passe dans le monde en juin 93 les
gendarmes interviennent dans cette
lettre pour des affaires de pédophilie
depuis deux jours l'instruction est
close mais la justice toujours muette
orinel ans commis à l'affluence des tec
tiendrait de plus en plus nombreux
promet protéger une composition de loi
visent à emporter le contrôle de
l'obligation scolaire les inspecteurs
iront dans les familles
l'édile tous les ans répond dirigeante
et un contrôle dans les établissements
susceptibles d'être en lien avec une
secte car jusque là les contrôles
portaient surtout sur l'hygiène ou la
maltraitance de l'enfant
les sanctions sur le contenu de
l'enseignement n'était jamais appliquée
si le texte est voté le niveau de
connaissances des enfants sera évaluée
chaque année dès l'âge de 6 ans en cas
de manquement les peignes euros jusqu'à
six mois d'emprisonnement et clinquante
mais fondamentaux pour les parents ou
les directeurs d'école apparentés à des
sectes de nouveaux cas de vache folle
dans les départements bretons des côtes
d'armor et dans celui du maine et loire
dans les deux cas les autorités
sanitaires ont procédé à la destruction
totale des troupeaux au total 148 ch la
crise économique et financière dans le
sud est asiatique a des répercussions en
europe le groupe suédois skf le numéro
un mondial des roulements à billes
annonce la suppression de 4000 emplois
au japon même la population inquiète de
la récession officiellement annoncée n'a
plus confiance en ses banquiers
préfèrent garder l'argent à domicile
conséquence un bout sur la vente des
coffres forts pour les particuliers
reprotage jean-paul chapelle appris que
l'économie japonaise tourne au ralenti
sauf dans un secteur l'indus et du
coffre fort le leader du marché a vu ses
ventes augmenter de 50% depuis le début
de l'année les japonais ont peur et
préfèrent garder leur argent à portée de
main
c'est ce petit modèle là 2000 francs qui
se vend le mieux
il correspond bien à la taille des
appartements au japon racing en bonne
place dans les grands magasins
le coffre individuelle devient produits
de première nécessité depuis que la
crise du secteur bancaire a ébranlé la
confiance des consommateurs
quatre sociétés de bourse ont déjà sévi
et puis des banques aussi je veux
maintenant et donc j'ai acheté un
confort et perd aussi on a un chez lui
tellement comme les taux d'intérêt sont
à 0 5%
ça ne sert plus à rien de placer son
argent la banque l'interview est là pour
répondre à la demande
les machines tournent au maximum de
leurs capacités ici on a recruté onze
personnes de plus et demander à tout le
monde de faire des heures
supplémentaires
on travaille même le dimanche parfois
nous on n'arrive pas à produire
suffisamment
la dernière ruer sur les coffres forts
remonte à 1995 à l'époque les japonais
voulait mettre à l'abri leur valeur
après le tremblement de terre de kobé
aujourd'hui le pays tout entier redoute
un nouveau séisme
cette fois financiers le suite du voyage
du président américain winden en chine
droits de l'homme mais commerce font bon
ménage il a signé de très gros contrats
et dans le même temps
eh bien il s'est livré à un cours sur
les libertés individuelles devant les
étudiants de pékin à l'intérieur même de
l'université d'où était partie la
révolte de 1989 sur place
isabelle bechler et tristan do le petit
peuple de pékin a été bloquée comme
souvent qu'elle son tour en attendant
les limousines de l'escort
présidentielle américaine
curiosité plutôt des veillant tout
autant que le message de bill clinton
avait des côtés très nouveau et
particulièrement rafraîchissant pour un
public chinois au niveau américain la
liberté et la liberté de l'individu par
opposition aux abus de pouvoir du
gouvernement contre les contrôles du
gouvernement c'est notre héritage mais
dans la prestigieuse université de pékin
certains ne voulaient pas s'en laisser
compter qu'en amérique aussi et les
problèmes de droits de l'homme comme
dans tous les pays
les sushis et nous ici du président
américain a drainé les jeunes bien au
delà des 400 étudiants sélectionnés par
l'université ils ont même débordé le
service d'ordre
je pense que s'il ya tant de divergences
entre la chine et les états unis sur la
question des droits de l'homme c'est
parce que la chine est méconnu je pense
que le voyage clinton va permettre
d'améliorer la liberté d'expression dans
notre pays
c'est donc quand ni de des jeunes
chinois que le président américain
arrivé sur scène avec ces discussions de
mes yeux
en marge de son discours sur la
démocratie les droits de l'homme miss
hilton vient de signer aujourd'hui des
conflits commerciaux pour plus de 12
milliards de francs dans lesquelles
boeing se taille la part du lion
comme quoi la franchise l'empêchera
e-commerce autorités chinoises ont
accepté les remarques sur les libertés
et les droits de l'homme du président
clinton
mais ils ont répondu à leur façon comme
toujours pour eux un pays d'un milliard
et demi d'habitants a d'abord besoin de
stabilité de valeur patriote quelle
image de cette unité spéciale de l'armée
chinoise chargée
chaque jour de monter les couleurs
nationales au centre de la place
tiananmen à pékin
isabelle bechler d'étendre la journée
commence toujours pendant la nuit noire
une heure avant le lever du soleil dans
les chambres et des gardes du drapé
conditions par classe
c'est une pour des abords de la cité
interdite et une centaine de soldats
vont y passer trois ans de leur
existence
admission repas loisirs instruction tout
se déroule la triés sur le volet pour
leur fini leur attitude militaires et
leur esprit patriotique ont la charge la
plus prestigieuse qu'ils soient dans un
régime autoritaire
ils sont 80 du drapeau le symbole de ce
qu'on appelle la nouvelle fille
tous les matins des venues de partout
attendent quasi religieusement le lever
du drapeau révolutionnaire
je les ai toujours admiré quand j'étais
petit soldat je trouve que c'est
symbolique de la beauté masculine
chaque pas est soigneusement mesurées à
l'entraînement 75 cm et pas un de plus
que 38 pas très exactement permettent de
traverser l'avenue jusqu'à la hante les
drapeaux kouroussa émouvant un geste
ample pour déployer l'emblème
révolutionnaire et tous les provinces ne
retiennent leur souffle
c'est à l'heure précise du lever du
soleil à l'horizon que le drapeau doit
flotter aussi mettre six mois après le
premier devoir du matin c'est l'heure du
petit déjeuner le temps faim se
restaurer les dragons floch de plus d'un
quart d'heure les hommes qui ont du goût
de cuisine bonheur sans compter ceux qui
restent en faction sur la place
la tâche est bien fatigante parfois dans
le froid de l'hiver où la canicule
estivale
il arrive qu'on peut gagner par le
sommeil je n'ai rien que de penser à
l'intérêt supérieur mère-patrie la
fatigue c'est parce qu'ils imaginent et
c'est un grand honneur compagnies
chinoises
tout le prestige de la chine
révolutionnaire est donc concentré dans
cette étoffe de sa m sur 3 noué avec la
précision d'un calligraphe dénouer de
manière être instantanément gonflé par
le vent le rouge du drapeau représente
tous les martyrs de la révolution
ils ont fait ce sacrifice de leur vie
c'est leur essentielle à notre drapeau
rouge telle autre email le jaune des six
toiles en temps de prospérité politique
autour du grand parti communiste notre
mission est de protéger la majorité et
le caractère sacré de notre rapport au
prix de notre vie s'il le faut
les journées des gardiens du drapeau à
leurs réserves quand même quelques
instants de détente mais le dow est
toujours bien droit ne pas perdre les
bonnes habitudes inculquer à la dure et
pour parer à toute éventualité quelques
bribes d'anglais enseignée par des
étudiants bénévoles puis l'instruction
reprend dans toute la rigueur unifiée
pour apprendre à 6g leur colonne
vertébrale des interminables faction
baïonnette au clair ils sont aussi des
guyanes et sans pitié
cette pointe doit leur rappeler que les
vertèbres cervicales droitière ou bauchi
sont également proscrits après un an de
ce régime aux jeunes recrues de faire
leurs preuves et de marcher vers la
gloire au portugal référendum sur la
libéralisation de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse ivg a été rejeté
à une faible majorité il hier mais le
scrutin a été surtout marquée par une
abstention record près de 60 pour cent
un résultat qui pose plus de questions
qui n'ont permis n'est effet c'est un
pour qui des sur deux est un catholique
pratiquant
c'est sans doute pour cette raison que
la légalisation de l'avortement a été
rejetée hier
on croyait le portugal entrer dans la
modernité à l'heure de l'exposition
universelle de lisbonne 25 ans après la
révolution des oeillets ce petit pays de
10 millions d'habitants ne semblent pas
prêts avaient commis sont les moeurs les
militantes féministes et de gauche ont
vu l'entrée le débat c'était oublier que
le sujet dans ce pays profondément
catholique est d'abord une affaire de
conscience individuelle
69% des électeurs ont boycotté le
référendum
le oui l'a emporté d'une courte tête et
ce soir le parti socialiste wallon frais
qu'il retirait définitivement au projet
la révolution des oeillets en 1974 les
portugais n'avait jamais été appelé à se
prononcer par ce type de référendum la
question était difficile c'est un sujet
passionnel qui renvoient à des tas de
préoccupation dans un pays où l'église
catholique continue de jouer un rôle
important
on le voit sur près de cap la question a
divisé le pays honore la zone la plus
rurale
les partisans du non à lisbonne et dans
le sud
le oui l'a emporté le gouvernement
socialiste très embarrassé par ce
référendum au point de renoncer à toute
consigne de vote a compris que l'on ne
légifère pas les consciences
y aller ch portugaise continueront
d'avorter en toute illégalité dans des
cliniques privées où les repas y mesut
feront appel à des faiseuses d'anges au
risque de leur vie
les allemands transforment leur
benchmark en engrais ne sont pas tombés
sur la tête en fait avec l'arrivée de
l'euro ce sont des centaines de millions
de benchmark qui vont être détruits et
les spécialistes ont trouvé un moyen de
les recycler werlen pauline est là
prenez un billet périmé de 10 ou 20
deutsch mark
découpez le en miss en morceaux mélanger
le aux déchets habituel avec un peu de
terre fraîches
la recette est unique au monde laisser
mijoter le tout pendant huit à dix
semaines pour obtenir un engrais enrichi
en billets de banque
cette économiste et très écologique
sinon on ne va pas faire fortune mais le
drunch marque nous a ouvert de nouveaux
horizons 200 kg de billets arrive soit
40 millions de dollars 360 millions de
francs
fascinant on dirait des confettis avec
ces différentes couleurs
mais ce sont bien des deux marques mme
royer ainsi que mélanger aujourd'hui
nous on est partis avec l'idée que tout
était tranchant mas le dhj pas compris
avec les fleurs qu'il est vraiment
parfait il est magique
ce match marque sur symbole de
prospérité auquel les allemands sont si
attachés à désactive lui voit défiler
des millions de doses par colombo on
voit briller l'umq en aluminium des
milliards avec la mort du deux marques
programmée pour 2012 c'est du pain béni
pour recevoir 2000 tonnes de billets de
banque
le sac vaut 15 francs rien n'indique une
quelconque présence du deutschemark mai
dans les jardins du nord de l'allemagne
on a déjà versé une petite fortune 30
millions de marks 120 millions de francs
dans des pots de fleurs lors nos clients
sont donc via styles peuvent rêver avec
notre anglais et 60 propriétaires 2010
deutsche mark qu'ils enterrent dans leur
potager en allemagne ces deux milliards
et demi de billets en deutschemarks
qu'il faut détruire que coûte avant 2002
pour laisser place nette
ils ne sont pas perdus pour tout le
monde et parfois l'argent n'a pas
d'odeur comme on dit ainsi les nouveaux
riches de russie dont l'origine de la
fortune n'est pas toujours prêts m yens
dépensés en liquide leur argent dans les
stations balnéaires italienne de la côte
adriatique notamment à san benedetto là
ils partagent leur temps entre la plage
et les achats et ça représente un tel
volume d'affaires que des dizaines
d'emplois ont été créés rome alain tchad
la plage de san benedetto sur la grille
est même en ce début de saison elle fait
le plein c'est que ces populations s'est
fait une spécialité de moscou je suis
mon secours
eh oui si les touristes russes
représentent 12 % de la clientèle c'est
le groupe le plus important loin devant
les allemands et ils dépensent beaucoup
plus que les allemands car ils
s'appellent lier l'utile à l'agréable
ils font des affaires ils achètent des
marchandises et à l'est les reventes ont
dit et fait confiance aux italiens pour
exploiter le filon
les juges ont pris en charge dès leur
arrivée et entre deux moments de plage
on leur fait faire le tour des centres
commerciaux du point spécialisés ou
dimitrije ivan peuvent tranquillement
faire leurs achats avec une prédilection
pour la lingerie féminine
après quoi on les emmène dans un
entrepôt comme celui ci
où ils vont pouvoir faire emballer
soigneusement leurs jambes l'être dans
de gros cartons soigneusement scellé
sinon à l'arrivée il ne reste plus rien
destination ce business payé cash en
dollars génère des milliards est devenu
vital pour l'économie de la région
l'arrivée des russes c'est une très
bonne chose pour les entreprises de la
région
ils ont beaucoup d'argent ce qui permet
aux entreprises de sortir de la crise
que nous visions ces dernières années de
nouvelles sociétés se sont créés après
l'arrivée des russes est elle due
uniquement du marché russe tout le monde
y trouve donc son compte
les commerçants de la région et ont
retrouvé une nouvelle jeunesse et les
russes qui rentre au pays avec des
marchandises durant facturés
car c'est là un des gros avantages du
système les dollars des vacanciers
n'avait pas d'odeur en arrivant mais ils
n'étaient pas forcément très propre à
l'achat du circuit ils sont blanchis à
san benedetto la plupart des profiteurs
du système ferme les yeux
mais quelques-uns plus clairvoyant il ya
la mafia russe derrière tout cela au
pape
ces touristes par de lancer l'union
soviétique avec de l'argent pas très
propres prêtés par la mafia est investi
6,6 dans des activités diverses tourisme
et commerce achètent des produits
italiens qu'ils revendent le double la
police italienne l'a trouvée jusqu'ici
rien à redire à ce système et un
antonoff se poser sur l'aéroport
d'ancône tout proche pour faire le plein
de ses marchandises
toute belle blanche beaucoup plus légal
maintenant à la veille des vacances une
formule à découvrir en france passer ses
congés sur un bateau sans prendre la mer
une manière d'arriver toujours à bon
port tout en restant à quai avec vous et
gabriel correspondant à la
trinité-sur-mer de la société botanique
il fait sa tournée et où ça sujet que
tout se passe bien pour les locataires
ce séjour a commandé bien philippe et
emmanuel pour louer cette vedette pour
une semaine l'occasion de découvrir la
région et pour ces terriens qu'ils
ignorent tout de la mer est une première
approche mais en reste opaque est
magique
découverte je passe à rien à voir avec
une location se fait maintenant quatre
jours qu'on est là elle ça nous donne
bachir peut-être des envies pourquoi pas
deux peut-être de ce fait à la voile
pourquoi pas 2000 à 8000 points la
semaine du voilier aux catamarans de
luxe
il y en a pour tous les goûts et toutes
les bourses la société est présente dans
une vingtaine de corps elle démarche des
propriétaires et leur propose de louer
leur bateau quand ils ne l'utilisent pas
je ne voulais prendre mon bateau on est
mené mais comment n'occupe pas le bateau
en permanence cela en est t on
et quand même partie quelle semaine ça
me permettait donc de voir le bateau
toujours en fonctionnement ouvert et
éviter qu'ils s'abîment situé au coeur
des cités balnéaires le bateau audel
autres un hébergement idéal il peut
aussi faire naître des vocations
car finalement amadou c'est quand même
fou pour naviguer sont intelligents et
wimbledon en angleterre nathalie tauziat
en quart de finale s'est qualifié
aujourd'hui en battant lé anglaise
samantha smith
chez les hommes le dernier français
sébastien grosjean vainqueur surprise de
l'espagnol mantilla s'apprête lui à
rencontrer l'américain pete sampras
la coupe du monde de football est une
fête n'est pas un point tel que certains
imaginaient dans la commune d'ozoir la
ferrière par exemple où est installée
l'équipe du brésil certains avaient cru
que ce serait la fête permanente et bien
ils en sont pour leurs frais tout autant
qu'aux abords du stade de france à saint
sébastien guibert hayward la semaine
dernière le village mais il installé
près du stade de france à saint denis a
été purement et simplement des montées
trop peu de visiteurs
la fête et les bénéfices annoncés pour
les commerçants du village se sont
transformés en fiasco est en dépôt de
bilan
prévert désillusion aussi pour les
habitants d'ozoir la ferrière en seine
et marne
l'équipe du brésil devait s'y entraîner
tous les jours deux fois par jour 6000
places de gradins boutiques et
restaurants ont donc été installées pour
accueillir les supporters
petit problème l'entraîneur brésilien a
réduit au minimum les entraînements
publics
un seul la semaine dernière avec 3000
passe à donner pour toute une semaine
c'est un peu et donc évidemment il ya
beaucoup de demandes mais on est mieux
gérer d'autres cas pénurie du coup
obtenir une place officiellement
gratuite relève de l'exploit le parking
est obligatoire il coûte 40 francs on
obtient aussi une place de plus en
sirotant un cocktail
20 francs quant aux habitants de jouarre
il l'a présenté livret de famille
justificatif de domicile pour obtenir en
priorité ces prêts subit tout à fait ce
que ça te répètes quoi enfin ça ternit
un peu cette ambiance de fête il y avait
un petit peu délicat
je trouve quand même avec l'entraînement
aussi d'accord nous n'aurons pas les
matchs sans but en entraînement c'est
dommage si l'équipe du brésil ne
parvient pas en finale l'opération au
douar brasil risque d'être déficitaire
les organisateurs espèrent donc
accueillir beaucoup d'autres spectateurs
autour du stade d'entraînement lors de
concerts notamment ce n'est pas gagné
celui de la star brésilienne gilberto
gil vendredi soir à 100 francs la place
n'a tiré qu'un petit millier d'amateurs
retour à l'instant sur un magnifique cet
après midi à montpellier avec la
victoire des allemands 2 1 à montpellier
finalement tout s'est bien passé
les supporters allemands vous le voyez
sur ces images en direct il centre ville
se sont bien comportées il faut dire
qu'il y avait de nombreuses forces de
police en ville et aux abords du stade
mais il faut tout de même souligner que
tout s'est bien passé
cet après midi culture et sport font
aussi bon ménage le prix goncourt
l'écrivain daniel picouly est un fan de
football
la nostalgie de l'épopée de l'équipe de
france en suède
c'était en 1958 et sa célébrité
d'aujourd'hui bien permis de rencontrer
ses idoles de l'époque au portage arnal
mars michel aulas on ça comme 60 le
coeur battant du ballon avec par exemple
en maillot rouge le blanc ont chanté en
tenue bleue le pèlerinage au stade
mythique s'imposait pour daniel picouly
il vient de placer à nouveau libre dans
les filets du succès le 13e but
souvenirs de gosse de la coupe du monde
58 les crochets ou failli l'empêcher
il jouait dans la même cour que le
brésil contre eux hélas la double
fracture de jonquet nous a mis des
bâtons dans les jambes
si jean qu'elle n'avait pas été blessé
et jugeant qu'elle était mais ce que ce
truc m'étais fait en gros que si son cas
n'ait pas été blessé on avait notre
chance ou malchance mais on se comprend
c'était très réduit il faut pas vraiment
la science combien les brésiliens nous
étaient un peu supérieures il foule avec
la malle comme avec l'adversaire bon
joignent si bien que l'article de la
faim a dit mme chan daniel picouly en
découle est allé jusqu'à boire l'eau du
canigou afin d'attraper une maladie
explications la reine a été pour moi un
modèle c'était le brésilien qui était le
meilleur ailier droit du mans mais pour
moi le meilleur de tous les temps et ce
type avait une jambe plus courte que
l'autre faisait des bruits complètement
déroutant et pourquoi cette jambe tout
cas parce qu'il a vu la polio mais nous
aimons un gamin je me disais donc pour
bien dribbler
il faut avoir une élite et j'essayais de
l'attraper c'est incroyable
ma mère quand elle va dire ça elle va
être complètement effrayé les mamans
d'aujourd'hui essayer de comprendre
quand un gosse rêve
il veut absolument tout savoir de son
héros est vrai que lui mangeait pareil à
voir les chaussures de la même marque
c'est un gamin la bombe des bleus encore
des modèles pour piccoli daniel le gamin
gonfler le torse comme un joueur de
rugby foot il ne rêvait pas de
ressembler à ses idoles il était juste
fontaine justo le héros record man des
buts en coupe du monde avec ses tresses
boulet le canonnier france est tellement
célèbre il n'a pas besoin de prêts dont
il s'appelle juste fontaine
le 150e anniversaire de la naissance du
peintre paul gauguin donne lieu à une
magnifique exposition suisse à martigny
une simple oeuvres de la période
bretonne du pain et pour se souvenir
qu'il s'était installé à pont-aven et
puis aussi de la période polynésienne
ils seront présentés georges bégoux
pascal plus les pires au vent les petits
rangs bienne et mes souvenirs reviennent
le gauguin polynésiens lhermitte des
marques lee c'est sûrement le plus
populaire veux tu que je te dis finir
nepad au marquis toutes les
caractéristiques de son génie s'épanouit
semble large vers plats aux couleurs
faux au delà de l'exotisme qui
n'engendrerait et suresnes et
perspectives et marque les contours des
formes voluptueuses de la nature et les
personnages
il remplit ses toiles d'une vie
quotidienne paradisiaque
ce qui ne l'empêchent pas de souffrir de
l'exil et du manque de reconnaissance du
monde de l'art européen l'exposition de
martigny et riche en talent le tahitien
met également en oeuvre majeure de la
période breton au moins ce qu'il a fait
en bretagne pour moi personnellement
c'est peut-être le plus important que
l'ue va fé ati t
par exemple il a nettement aux estampes
japonaises
quel tableau qui annoncent m'attrister
gens
avant de naviguer sur le pacifique gogh
a fait une longue étape dans le village
de pont-aven où se trouve un groupe de
jeunes peintres parmi lesquels emile
bernard qui est le premier à cerner les
personnages à l'exploit zone et une
technique dont gauguin jusque-là
influencé par les impressionnistes
s'empare et améliore gauguin ne
travaillait pas seulement d'après nature
il emprunte parfois ses compositions aux
photographies dont il avait une grande
connexion peut être est ce cela qui
attire notre visite à privilégier le
photographe henri cartier bresson ya
plus de gens tu regardes les gens
pensent y pense y penser quoi ce sont
les enfants du chant bien observé chez
remettre à l'écran lumineux
pourra-t-il jamais remplacer un carré de
toile quelques couleurs et un peu de
génie avant de quitter le rappel du
principe de l'actualité d'aujourd'hui